kyle how are we doing i'm doing good dr
john
when my wife turned 18 her mother opened
up credit cards
in my wife's name without her no how
much
about 15 000 she didn't pay a penny on
it has she
no oh geez and so we've been uh we found
out shortly before we got married which
has been about four years ago now
and all because i answered a phone call
that my wife didn't
know so i answered it and turned out she
was behind on the payments so we figured
it all out wow
and her dad her dad doesn't know and
the reason is that she couldn't get a
credit card because
uh they'd had a credit card bankruptcy
prior
years so she stole from her child
exactly and this she stole from her
adult child
which makes this a whole different ball
game right exactly
and i want paid back okay
and so we uh we've been working on it
trying to think of
different ways to do it and uh you know
being that her dad doesn't know
i guess he didn't take the bankruptcy
very well because the mother has always
handled
money so my wife's very concerned
that him finding out about this will be
you know
more than he can handle and with
with some mental issues and so we're
so here's the deal kyle i'm gonna save
your heart here okay
let's hear it you're not getting a penny
back just just go ahead
it's not going to happen um the choices
you
you guys have to make are filing a
dispute with the credit bureau
right saying that these are stolen these
charges are fraudulent i never have
y'all done that
no no it's been too many years um i
would dispute it
at least have a write a letter in
writing
the second thing you all need to decide
is are you going to
call the police on your on your
mother-in-law and say she robbed me
do you need to go get another cr does
your wife need to go get another social
security number
because if it happened once it could
happen again and once she's
put fraudulent stuff put a police report
out there that somebody stole my thing
and and
took out credit cards somebody told my
social security numbers took out credit
cards
then the next thing is i need to get a
new social security number so that mom
can't steal from me anymore
and then y'all got to go move on about
your day the chances of you getting this
back are zero the chances of y'all end
up going to war with your in-laws is a
hundred percent
and i just i don't know the value and
the benefit of that
you okay okay what do you think about
that
well you see hey you're like me and i
guarantee you've already spent that
money
yeah yeah yeah it's i mean it's been
there eating at me you know i've been
paying
you know my wife was paying for it
originally she said well i'm just gonna
keep my job pay it well we had a little
boy he's home
so she's home with him now and that's
where i wanted to be that's why i love
that
and so now i'm eating that 420
a month and we haven't even been hardly
paying anything down on it we
you know reconsolidated it and made it
to where we can
you know manage no you consolidated it
with other loans
yeah it will with all because the three
loans together
and we just consolidated those three
okay
and i think i the man i know her dad
would not it i don't see anything ending
bad i think he's going to be mad about
it yeah
but i think he'd find a way to come up
with the money they have assets to sell
they're both retired
okay so who's telling you not to call
them
my wife she is scared to death she cries
about it it just and you know 2020 was
hard for everybody and so we got a
little bit behind so guess what i cut
i quit paying first those credit cards i
hate
here's the thing though it's it's in
your heart
it's a it's an existential deal
but for the banks if they don't care you
got to keep paying that bill
right and we and we got caught back up
and everything but
i i did pretty well sold a project her
mother knew that we sold the project
well
the va the credit cards had called her
mother in that time because they keep
all the phone numbers
and so they called her well then she
called us why aren't you paying the
credit cards
well when she found out we we started
paying on
or that we sold a big project made some
good money she
told my wife when are you going to pay
off the debt and i just
i've lost my mind over that that's
what's the reason for this call right
now hey that's fair
that's i i'd be upset and fired up too
um but what you're doing is you are
allowing an input
but you're stuck with the output right
right so cut your mother-in-law off
you're done you don't get a vote in my
life
i'm not you're a thief and now you're
dishonest
and um you stole from your child and
i'm we're done with that if someone
stole from
their 19 year old their 18 year old and
it was a it was a moment of weakness
things got bananas around the house we
were gonna lose something
and they circled back three or four five
years later and said i screwed up in a
major way i'm embarrassed and i'm
ashamed and i'm gonna make it right
that's one thing but then when someone's
calling saying hey you guys need to get
these creditors off my
off my back um i mean
no you that's your true colors that's
who you are you know what god be with
you go have fun with your life i'm
you're not having any influence in my
life you're not going to see my kid
you're not going to poison my wife
anymore we're going to create our own
legacy and we're going to move on
from somebody who's not a thief and
somebody who's not dishonest
that's it and i know that that's hard
because your wife's not going to be on
board with that is that right
that's right okay now have you sat down
with your wife
and said i need to be vulnerable here
and there's a hundred percent chance
you've not done this i'm setting you up
okay so just know we're on the same team
here
um i'm being vulnerable here
i committed my life to loving you i
committed my life to protecting you i
committed my life to being vulnerable
with you
and your your mom stole from her child
your mom has continued to beat us up
over her debt
that we're having to pay off in a season
we don't have the money to be paying it
off
and you have a dream of staying home
with our son
i've got a dream of giving the woman of
my life whatever she wants
however i can love and support her
and every time your mom calls i feel
like she's
hurting her family again and again and
again and
i'm asking for us to take a season off
from
having your mom in our life and
letting your wife truly hear your heart
on this deal because my guess is it only
comes up when you get one of these calls
when you write that 400
check and it comes out as an explosion
which then comes out as you verse her
mom
and nobody wins in that exchange exactly
if it comes out you versus her mom she
has to defend her mom just because
she's got to defend you just because and
sh the person who loses there is your
wife
if you come at her as not me versus mom
but me plus you that's a whole different
equation
right but uh i mean what about her dad
in the end should i burn the whole place
down and let everybody know you know
there's a fault in the wiring just by
telling them
if you want to lose your marriage over
go ahead man you think think so
i don't want to do that your wife has
said please don't do that
right and do you want to be right or do
you want to be in love and married
no i want to be in love and married okay
then man this is a uh
this is a painful painful hard
fifteen thousand dollar pill to swallow
sucks
hate it well you know what i mean i can
deal with it
yeah but but it is it happened and then
yeah let's let's
man let's work triple and quadruple and
get this thing knocked out it may be
that your
mo your wife's dream of staying at home
is gonna have to be put on hold for six
to nine months so she can crank that
out yeah and that you can go home and
hold that baby while she does uber eats
or something like that and
cranks that thing out and pays that
sucker off
yeah absolutely and then everybody can
be back on the same page but here's the
thing
all of this conversation starts from two
places number one we're drawing a
boundary no more mom
no more mother-in-law in our life for a
season at least
number two um this is not
us versus them this is me plus you
this is me connecting with my wife with
someone i love and i want to be engaged
with here and
um ever it's not your mother anymore
it's just this lady that keeps hurting
her family
and i'm asking that she not be around
her kid i don't want him getting this
stuff it i
i'm asking that she not be around us
right now this is hard
and i want to focus on you guys not the
other way around
um listen if i'm you i'm in the
exact same place kyle i want that money
back
i'd want to call everybody i'd go knock
on and and
talk to to my my father-in-law
face-to-face hey listen here man i'd do
it
i'd want to do it but if my wife said
hey please don't then i'm going to honor
that
because she knows more about that
situation than i do and um
and then you gotta just swallow it and
move on with your day
life's too short man um and then i would
strongly strongly recommend that your
wife get a new social security number
your your mom is not somebody to be
trusted with that kind of information